the Pocky is down bashing sends it deep and
away we go Allan furing put scoring Thomas
Hickey with you he's between the benches as the
Islanders wrap up a brief two game home stand
they have scored the first go on fight straight
but right away from the bottom of their Circle
the wild Take the Lead 19 seconds in Pat maroon
steps into one and he goes top shelf on bar Lov
that a while just get the puck in deep a little
chip and Chase poino gets in on the puck in a
hurry and the Islanders three guys behind the
net and a tough angle shot for varlamov as he
turns to his right he's not even watching and
that's maroon that goes up and over the should
from behind the net to The Far Side Islanders
will break it out although this pass Miss pass
Joe turned back the other way by bro Marco
Rossi he's scoring backto back gam drops it
up and a tough angle shot turned toide by VAR
come on got that one for Matt Baldi and again
he missed seven games due to an upper body
injury he's back for his third consecutive
game on the ice Wild on a three-game road trip
play three games over four days in the state
New York moving on to Madison Square Garden on
Thursday and then in Buffalo on Friday B the up
the wall Rin across frea floats one towards
the net battling front pelic went down barl
trying to locate it still loose and walstrom the
last ditch efforts going to backhand it all the
way down oh Minnesota has allowed a power play
goal in six of its last seven games the New York
Islanders power play one for eight over its
last four there's Nelson into B driving the
net a backhand shot just missed and it's picked
up in stride by Brandon D ha and he'll take it
one on two through the neutral zone challenged by
Dobson got a shot off for Lama zarella took a hit
from cik as gave the puck to capris off he loads
and fires one off scott m field left both Scott
Mayfield and Adam Pell playing tonight turning
shot this one runs up behind bar off's net and
another penalty call trying to find Felino at
the doorstep Nelson closes in on him ericon X
shot misses around on the near side Middleton
threw it to the net marov had to make a save
Islanders trying to get it out finally Ang ball
does but it came right to Middleton nice job by
that Eric NE line just simple hockey using the
back of the neet as an out themselves physical
strong along the boards and getting the punch
of the net lee with the takeway w driving and
a shot shrug away and he'll March out to Center
angles it off the near wall closing in on him is
hunt kayin Addison behind the neet he's squeezed
against the wall by fashing who creates a turnover
fashing to the front The Bouncing Puck is loose
still loose in front out of the corner rifle to
Center by Roman off touch in Matt Martin butb goes
in hard after it and he'll create a turnover pass
to dos and he [Applause] scores Noah doson with
the Slap Shot the Islanders tie it [Music] up of
course there Noah doson simple play though just
get it in and as we've seen so many times as
cikas line gets in on the for check Clutterbuck
takes his man out Matt Martin is there cikas is
helping out okay let it get back to Noah and
he just sends Howitzer towards the net that
beats flurry simple hockey great result simple
hockey Romano finds poock in a soft spot puns
doesn't shoot Holst from in front redirects
somehow flurry while falling over made the
stop wild in Baldi from caprisa SS it back
in a shot found the iron and skyrockets out
of play that was Jonas broin who went stick side
on barlon like to jump up on the play especially
broin and wild were able to hang on to that
puck just just long enough hang ball crosses
in and then he'll curl and wait pass intended
for AO and that's redirected out yeah I got to
make sure on that pass and ball back in has
walstrom he trick to Dr to The N he scores
what a play for oler wallstrom the Islanders
set their first lead of the night move after
a pass from Ang ball and just gets it around
to his forehand and we've seen him snap it
before watch the move get it to the forehand
bang right up on the top hand corner in the
toy department tremendous goal from Oliver wst
that's the ability that this young player has
and it's good to get the power play going arzel
again fouron four continuing for 20 seconds hold
up hers on the back hand flashy move and he
goes glove side flurry was ready for it their
Lee is Harman and Clutterbuck stor him out of the
box Hartman immediately got the pass and he came
off his stick wound around broin to Baldi one
timer and that one changes directions back up
to the point BR fa's all alone this way fa walks
down the wall and then he's closed in on by Paso
here's larious shot they score that may have
been deflected in front but L Terry from the
deep slot has tied the game but just under
8 minutes to go in the second period there
were bodies in front but later is the first
one through the handshake line the wild the
controlling the puck getting going from point to
point and watch this shot from the from the point
as he turns around creates a little time and space
further than that and now certainly arlam off his
his screen looking for a way to find the puck
I've seen that this now about five times a ton
of it in the first period That's a forward
playing up top first it was Matt baly will
continue to show it examples so the Islanders
continue to pressure long shot by holst's kick
back and now a hook the Islanders will have
a power play flurry still without his stick
Highlanders have an extra attacker here's
pjo flry makes the Stop and it's stuck to
it two goals for each side on 22 shots wild
haven't had a shot on golf power play yet
tonight zukar soft spot between the circles for
Rossy out High Johansson to zukar back through
what time are they score Kil capris off Minnesota
takes a 3-2 lead on the power play for Kil Capri
off his fourth goal of the season that's now 12
points in 12 games this year it was knocked down
in front of the net and then this time they're
able to to get it through you can see there's
the first off opportunity to get it through
got to shade him just a little bit more and
the Islanders give him too much room and he
just drills it up and over the glove of barl
off no chance there as it gets right through the
seam and barley gets a piece of it but just not
enough not many guys can get that much wood
on it flicks it ahead for ericon a although
here Ang ball is the one who settles this down
Ang Ball's under attack though he's got to be
careful maron's going to take it away Pat Maron
to the doorstep they score a turnover in The
Islander Zone awesome and it's Ericson e to make
it 42 yeah just trying to do just a little bit
too much and then b gets stripped of the puck
by Eric s and excuse me by Pat Maru they don't
win three be part of three Stanley Cups and look
at he just never quit stays with it never takes a
penalty finally wins the battle and gets his
head up in a hurry and yeah those ones those
ones can't happen I understand the mindset from
b ball Island had it two one one lead in this
hockey game uhoh look out here two on one doer
goes low and burlov isn't exactly sure but knows
it's underneath of him somewhere and he'll hold
on and get the whistle again another mistake by
the Islanders give up a two-on one after giving
up two goals and shoots the puck and Barley's
just able to squeeze it just just enough see
where this Puck was when the referee makes a
call I can't see it now Harley's got it number
another two-on-one developing for the wild at
Harman in has Johansson he elects to shoot it
himself bar Lao got down on his BS and made the
save off the face off zaho across
loock shot knocked down spun to
the front comes all the way through and
that'll do it tonight so the Islanders
still have not beaten Minnesota
at home since February of 2019